it seems implausible but the authorities
are taking no chances
whatsoever trained marksman police armed
with thermal imaging cameras
firefighters with tranquilizers and
helicopters have been deployed in a
small French town near Paris and they're
all on the hunt for a tiger this is a
photo taken of the alleged big cat as it
sloped towards the safety of a wooded
area it was first spotted in a car park
this morning by a woman too afraid to
leave her vehicle so she called her
husband and it's auntie Peru is quite
afraid at the beginning especially
during all the time we cross the carpark
it's not usual to see a tiger when you
go to work in the morning the animal was
off in the middle of that rise I would
say 5 to 6 meters from her vehicle
residents were warned to stay indoors
and children kept at school as more
witnesses came forward to report
sightings of the Beast
we're simply intrigued but if at
nightfall they still haven't found him
then we'll be worried we send the photos
to Tiger expert Benjamin Mee he's the
director of dartmoor zoological park
these photos do look fairly Tiger II and
he has a big head there's a long tail
with a very long straight back it could
be a Bengal it could be an emirate
Uyghur but now it's lost I reckon it's
looking for somewhere to hide and I'd be
surprised as I'm hunting anything for a
couple of days because bribery bury at
the monkeys is scared in a few more days
is while than it is in the woods it will
start eating things that crosses paths I
dare say
where the animal came from is a mystery
a circus that pitched up in a town a few
days ago says it doesn't own any Tigers
and inquiries are being made at a big
cat wildlife park some 20 miles away but
the bigger mystery is where is Monty
ron's Tiger now Isis Joshi Sky News